this time another shift what direction
which way is it going it's going to the
left okay so this time again I started
my asymptotes my asymptotes going to
move one unit to the left right so here
it is it's no longer at x equals zero
it's now at x equals one now being that
that part of the graph has moved the
intercept is also moved the internet
wasn't one wasn't it right so now it's
going to be at fewer the origin so draw
your graph clean these through okay all
right let's pretty close ah that's moved
I might as well also move my point for
scale right that was it to one so now
where should it be
one one
again you're kind of locked in to where
x equals one has to be because I already
put in X equal minus one so that
distance must match absolutely alright
question four what's the difference
again I sort of think about all of these
in terms of that original graph that I
started with so how would you express
how much I particular the difference
yeah yeah good okay so I would add on to
that vertically multiplied by three
right so if I take out this song this
vertical asymptote it's still in the
same spot still an x equals zero okay
what happens to our intercept over here
now because our Y value let's go back to
what you mentioned indicator because our
Y value for this intercept is zero when
you multiply zero by three you end up
with zero so that's that stays put that
point always stays put okay now when I
join us through what has changed because
this is what we alluded to before graph
one a graph all look identical at the
moment so what must I just this is
breakfast scale right before it was at
two one
right if I pick 2 which is still going
to be twice as far away from the y-axis
right it's not gonna be two one anymore
it's gonna be two three cuz it's three
times higher okay
now when I put that across now my
scratch scale is all off in terms of Y
and X but that's okay that's okay
this could be three it could be three
hundred fifty three million so long as
it's consistent with itself and the
x-axis is consistent with itself all
fine okay and by the way on your if you
have a template right your template
should have a log graph on it hurt and
so you can use the same one for all of
them maybe I should swap me I should get
another one yeah tell you
you're talking about another point you
made yeah yeah so so you can pick that
or you could go you're going here it
would also be fun so in general for as
many branches as your graph has you
should have a point for scale but for as
many branches as a grab-bag
these all have one branch okay now
question five question five I'm not
going to breath I'm not going back uh or
perhaps I should say I've graphed it
already right have a look at this before
you dive into any pen to paper right
what could you do with this to make
things easier for yourself yeah change
the printer I could do that I suppose
I'm not sure if would help
what would you alright so this guy here
this is approach right this is 2 times X
it's 2 times X I can break that apart
right so as suggested I'm going to take
the 2 here and then I'm gonna add that
to the X but we know what log base 2 of
2 is it's just 1 so I'll just put that
around here so you can see I've already
graphed this graph it's right here
now before I move off that like cool
I've done it already right what's his
name
well it's just me because we we started
to graph this by saying okay I've moved
up that's what I've done okay but this
isn't this does not mean moved on why
did this become move up we already know
what this means right yeah
yep that is very good now in case you
didn't catch that right this is about a
vertical shift and this is about a
compression factor right just like if
you got y equals x and y equals 2x - x
has been squashed in okay this is
getting squashed in as well compare
these two it's not just that this is
this moved up now it's like of course
the intercept should be up top right
because it's been it's now twice as
dense right just like sine 2x is twice
as dense as sine X does that makes it
and that's also why you've gone up 1 1
instead of 2 1 right everything is
packed into a smaller space right so
just like we looked before and we said
oh you know with y equals x a horizontal
reflection and a vertical reflection
happen to be the same thing because of
the nature walls a horizontal stretch or
compression is the same as a vertical
movement up or down okay bit of an
interesting idea but the algebra speaks
for itself